hello everyone this next game was played
in California three days ago actually it
was the extra can open and it was played
between Jalalabad or and the legendary
Nigel short and the jabal actually want
the entire event with eight and a half
out of ten points and well when Joe Bala
plays a game he doesn't always win but
when he does he does is in great style
and I would like to show you a game he
played I believe this is the this is
round nine and it was it was just
amazing the entire game and the ideas he
had in this game and the winning
combination is beautiful and the
position in the end is also something
you'll very rarely see in a chess game
but well I'll just show you the game so
you can decide for ourselves so Joe Bob
Butler is the white and Nigel short is
black we have c4 e6
g3 the English opening we have b5 Bishop
to g2 Knight to f6 Knight to f3 Bishop
to e7 castles castles just you know
nicely developing Queen to c2 b6
preparing to develop the light square
Bishop C capture some d5 Knight captures
on d5 and 933 nc6
we have a rook to d1 and our Bishop to
d7 and well black would really really
like to put this c5 move and activate is
like square bishop so your ball plays v4
and this d4 kind of stops c5 because if
c5 would be played in simply D captures
on c5 Bishop captures on c5 and Knight
to g5 and well white is already
threatening checkmate and black would
have to weaken his position by playing
g6 or something
so after d4 we have a nice Knight to d7
we have E for kicking the knight Knight
captures on c3 big captures on c3 and
alchemy into c7 moving the Queen out of
this file that is occupied by the rook
and also preparing some c5 in the future
so we have Bishop set for attacking the
Queen by Chihuahua and now Bishop to d6
and now a lot of you would probably
capture this
and after the Queen recaptures simply
Bush II five but the develop which is e
five immediately so we have Bishop to e7
and now Joe Baba starts his master plan
that is h4 we have rook F to e8 and he
pushes h5 we have b5 by Nigel short and
h6 and short pushes g6 and okay Joe
bhava continues with his plan he
weakened the f6 square and he plays nice
to h2 we have a nice to be six and now
Knight to g4 preparing Knight to f6
check and now Nigel short finally
decides to push c5 so we have an ID to
f6 check the Knight has to be captured
because he's [ __ ] the forking the the
roti and the King so Bishop captures on
f6 each chapters on f6 and now this
discovers an attack on the Queen so we
have Queen to c8 we have Bishop captures
n b7 Queen captures on b7 and now
defunct captures on c5 n 94 and with
this little maneuver devala actually
want to pawn here but okay so it's a CC
pawn and with these F and H porn both
andar squares it's going to be really
hard for this dark Bishop to help out
with the attack but it's it's funny how
devala plays this so we have a Bishop to
d6 and this is this is okay move this is
a very nice output for the bishop and if
the night ever captures it then Jabbar
will simply undable his pawns by
capturing so Nigel plays Queen to at
three going for that f6 pawn and here
jabal finds a very interesting idea he
plays a four and now this f6 point is
captured well he will simply capture on
b5 and he will have two nice connected
point so the short captures here B
captures on a4 and now develop plays
rook to be for wood now with the temple
on tonight so we have nice to a5 and
here another very interesting move rook
to f4 now preventing the Queen from
capturing here and f6
so we have a queen to be
seven and now Joe Bella plays rook to be
for attacking the Queen and in this
tradition a probably Nigel short should
have considered returning the Queen back
to f3 going for the deaf six pawn again
and then probably short probably Duvall
would have to play wrote that for again
but actually he decided for Queen to d7
so we have Queen captures on a for now
going for that Queen exchange but short
plays in 96 we have rook a to be 1 and
now rook c8 we have rope to beat 7
attacking the Queen and Queen to e8 f 4
into h8 and now again
Javad finds a very very interesting idea
T plays Queen to b4 and if if black were
to play something well not something
other than preventing his idea
like maybe rope to d8 then Javon would
play rook to e8 87 attacking the Queen
and after Knight captures here and F
pawn captures on e7 he would be
threatening to capture the rook here and
also Queen t5 check followed by Queen to
g7 checkmate so a very you know funky
idea this queenie for move but nigel
sees this and he plays King back to back
to g8 preventing this idea so we have
Quinta a 4 again by Obama and now well
he has to find another plan
but Nigel makes it easy for him he plays
'if I've given up another pawn
just to activate his queen so we have F
captures on ee5 and Queen to e6
but now chavalla has is two pawns up and
he wants to create Queens immediately so
we have a green captures on b3 and white
is Nigel decide to do this well he is
down two pawns but these pawns are
doubled and he has a pest upon himself
so his idea is to trade Queens and then
you know put his a pond down the board
and we have Queen captures on b3 but now
Java doesn't capture with this rook he
captures with the other rook and he
allows nice to a5 working both books so
this is exactly what nice
the C plays Knight to a5 and develop
plays e6 and this is a this is a very
nice position it's it's even it's even a
nice puzzle if you think about it so
Nigel captures the rook Knight captures
on b3 and we have he captures on f7 with
check so only move here is King to h8
and in this position
Nigel doesn't capture the knight of
course and he I mean devala doesn't
capture the knife and he could even just
push a face into a queen and this would
also be winning for white but this is
the wider ball as play style is so much
fun he actually goes rock to e7 and now
he is threatening a force checkmate in
eight moves it's a very it's a very nice
idea I mean feel free to stop the video
and look for it yourself
and if you just want to see it then well
here it is
well doesn't really matter what black
plays nigel played the night - d -
because nigel saw what was going to
happen but nigel is such a such a great
gentleman that he allowed everyone else
to see it as well so we have rook to e8
check so black has the capture row
casters in the 8f captures any age with
Queen that's check so rook captures
Queen and now f7 and now this is
terrible for black white is threatening
to capture the rook the rook can't
really stop at this point from going
forward faith and even if you wanted to
he is to play something like rook to f8
with some silly ideas and then she would
get to Bishop to e5 checkmate so he
plays a couple of more moves only move
the rook to e1 check we have Kings to G
to rip the e to check King to H 3 and
now rook to f2 to prevent this spawn
from becoming a queen and I'll simply
Bishop to e5 check and the King has
nowhere to go only move is to cover up
to f6 and this is the position I want to
really show you it's so rare that you
will see a position like this what can i
play a point to f8 and well Queen into
mace he can pick a rook and also it's
checkmate you can simply capture this
rook and it's checkmate in one
Weston place simply c6 and again black
doesn't have a move where white can
simply choose when to checkmate black
and how you can even play something like
King to g2 and then you know just finish
the game next move
but as nigel short was such a gentleman
to allow your ballot to show his santa
combination he decides not to torture
him anymore and he played Bishop
captures on f6 with checkmate and yeah a
beautiful game and as like I said Java
doesn't win all of his games but when he
does it's a spectacle and yeah he also
wanted to it was a very strong event
with an eight and a half out of ten
points and well Nigel short and a couple
of very strong other players were all
with with eight points in second place
two of them were actually from Croatia
madam Basia to change even charge so
yeah that's it
I do hope you enjoyed this game as usual
you can check two of my previous videos
here and I would like to thank Jason
Jason Pierre Sweeney and Antonia
GlassFish for their contributions thank
you thankful guys that you appreciate it
and this is thank you for watching and
I'll see you soon